When I wrote the book,
I was primarily focused on the,
on the business situation because I was
looking at how companies can grow and
prosper.
And it seemed that empathy was the
biggest differentiator.
But you know,
what I've been most surprised about is
how much empathy is become a larger
trend.
Something that is being focused on at
the highest levels of government.
Even a Barack Obama has become our chief
empathy officer for the country.
Um,
and I've,
it's just been amazing to see when he
was at the saddleback ranch last year
and Rick Warren asked him,
why do you want to be pressed at it?
Uh,
the number one reason he gave was
because his grandmother had taught him
the value of empathy and he felt that
that needed to be brought back to
government and to America.
Um,
and when he was asked to choose the
supreme court nominee,
Obama said that he was looking for
someone who first and foremost had a
sense of empathy.
And this is a big deal.
People kind of flipped out on both sides
of the aisle.
And what does he mean by empathy?
What is empathy?
A good thing.
Is it a bad thing?
Uh,
your people on the right saying that,
oh,
by empathy,
he means we want someone who's a
pushover and that's a sign of what's
wrong with this country.
It seems like empathy has gotten a bad
rap over the last 50 years in America.
We've kind of confused it with me.
Touchy feely or soft minded.
Um,
when,
what it really means is Jesse intuitive
ability to connect with other people.
And Barack gets that and I think he's
leading us to a different place.
It's a sign of Obama's ability to
connect with people that we don't call
him President Obama.
We call him barack.
The people I know referring to him by
his first name.
Like he's one of us.